vamos lá a água que prazer estar aqui
méxico 15 em deus ou à tona torcida mas
esse não vai deixar
ae ainda bem que vocês já pensaram ou
circo em mágico que vence vai ficar essa
aula
outro que faz
a que tipo de grupo
muito bem
pimpim então posso chamá los pessoal
pessoal vocês poderiam vir aqui é o
seguinte vamos ver se eu entendi cada um
de vocês vai ter que pegar a mala
quem é você pode vir parece tão triste
tão abusado por favor
op é coitadinho está chorando e poderia
ajudá lo
quem é que poderia vir aqui
a bailarina por favor é claro bailarina
precisa sempre pensar
i e 2013
a bailarina doente
por favor me ajuda aqui 112 preço
sabemos quem é o próximo candidato
aparece a magrela
tá bom por favor eo jogo na primeira a
equipe como você precisa dormir mais
forte para o seu lugar
só faltava ele aliás um figure creci mt
ae então vamos lá gente e do pieter
menezes curva mas o que que fosse comigo
eu agora no café da manhã
desculpa
se sair que parecem tom fortes jogam zos
bilhão para mim
olha assim
eu não sei porque eles estão olhando a
bola
e agora elásticos por favor
isso deve ser coisa de acrobata
então vamos bater hero um filho 13
eu tenho uma idéia todos juntos
podem me ajudar
comigo o 23
mas o que é que está acontecendo
vocês mas é o que a retal e cresci com
as duas é que minha volta
maravilhosas
bem vocês podem ficar assistindo agora
senhoras e senhores
apresentamos a eles com sua força e sua
energia
osa acróbatas
a soja picchu dettmer gol quem você
sempre quitinete e trilha cup pa
xuxa porque tinha ninguém me onde tem né
eu sempre acreditei e nem a cub pó
eu tenho orgulho de pina que tomou ontem
não é meu tipo não levo quessada versará
vou eu tenho nada de pinha tem toda a
roupa e treinar meu tipo não levo esses
adversários
ah
xuxa [ __ ] de ti nem houve quem perde
o chão a ponte tinha queixa de roubo
retina é e nem é tome pa
há um século
é bom
obrigada